into other covid related news
there are states out there
who aren't relying on the goodwill of
people with no good will to get
vaccinated
we're seeing spikes in all across the
country louisiana and arkansas florida
texas where we thought we were we had a
stranglehold on this thing we thought
the the worst days were behind us and
florida's infection rate right now is
approaching the highest levels of the
entire pandemic
child hospitalization rates are raising
it it is it is a worrying specter
all across the country but in certain
states it's worse
in my home state of california
not my home state but where i live right
now
they are taking action they are
mandating now it was just just announced
they are mandating vaccines for health
care workers
reading from the la times california
health care workers must be vaccinated
by end of september under new health
order in what officials characterized as
the first requirement of its kind in the
nation california ordered thursday that
health care workers statewide must be
fully vaccinated against covet 19 come
early fall the new mandate applies to
employees and hospitals skilled nursing
facilities clinics doctor's offices
hospice facilities dialysis centers and
most other health care settings and
stipulates that they complete their
inoculation regimen by september 30. a
quote here from an official as we
continue to see an increase in cases and
hospitalizations due to the delta
variant of covet 19
it's important that we protect the
vulnerable patients in these settings
dr tomas aragon state public health
officer and director of the california
department of public health said in a
statement today's action will also
ensure that healthcare workers
themselves are protected vaccines are
how we end
this pandemic
reasonable this is a reasonable approach
an expected approach
which is miles apart
it is
an alternate universe here in california
leadership wise relative to
florida
or arkansas
i know
farron cousins talked about it the other
day about asa hutchinson the former
senator and now governor
of arkansas who's like oh
i made a huge mistake y'all
i shouldn't have signed the ban on mass
mandates
because now people are dying all around
me all my constituents are in a in bad
shape
states like that
rules like that don't apply in certain
states california being one of them
it was just last week that governor
gavin newsom announced that california
healthcare employees would soon either
have to show proof of their vaccination
status or be subjected to regular
testing
the new order largely removes the
testing option and allows only limited
religious or medical exemptions from the
vaccine requirement employees who are
exempted would have to be tested
regularly twice a week if they work in
acute or long-term care facilities and
once a week in other health care
settings
unvaccinated employees would also have
to wear a surgical mask or respirator
such as an n95 while inside a facility
all of these are reasonable expectations
of the entire populace
but of course they're reasonable for
someone working in a healthcare setting
it is
disgraceful
the manner with which certain
municipalities certain states
have dealt with this
which is to say not dealing with it
to to act like this is a liberty issue
is nonsense
as i've talked about
if you choose not to wear a seat belt
you're only harming yourself
if you choose not to wear a helmet on a
motorcycle really it's it's just you
that you're gonna harm
this is not the case with the
coronavirus
if if i'm not vaccinated i am and i have
been for months but if i'm not and i'm
walking around asymptomatic just
breathing my filth all over everybody
and i get somebody sick and they die
that's on me
it's not about my liberty when i infect
someone and they die and i've encroached
upon their rights
it's not wearing a helmet it's not
wearing a seat belt it's not
liberty y'all
has nothing to do with that
it is basic decency and the protection
of our neighbors